what's going on guys this is rob and and
i'm wearing my headphones again yes i am
these are AKG headphones for those of
you guys who were wondering i can
remember the exact model name but they
are they're really really good
headphones i get some amazing sound in
these but in any event so you know i am
i ordered checks for my bank you know a
few weeks ago i'm awesome if you guys
are like Rob why the hell you tell us
about checks just bear with me for a
second all right just just hold on so I
ordered checks the other day and they
said it should take two to three
business days for them to come in so I
was like okay cool you know and so I've
been expecting yesterday I came back
from the gym which I'm back in the gym
now mmm yeah man I hurt everywhere but
it's nice but I i saw that i missed the
package from UPS and so I said okay
that's kind of weird why would you PS
deliver checks checks are in a box like
that being like this tiny little box
like it'd be delivered by the post
office so I check my mail and they
weren't in there so I was like okay
that's kind of weird so I figured you
know I'd be here when the when the UPS
guy got here around two o'clock or so
and and so sure enough you know the UPS
guy comes knocking you know knock knock
knock and I'm like hold on might get out
there and I sign the packet or sign for
the package and it's like this big box
and I'm like okay what the hell's in
this big box I open the box up and what
do I find lo and behold I find this cool
little note this is this really cool
note here's what this note says this
says 100,000 subscribers yeah you guys
know what's coming that's more than
double the size of a packed Roman
Colosseum and more than 10 times the
number of people who set the human
Domino world record I know there was a
world record for like human dominoes but
that's badass like people just falling
down that's amazing we understand the
dedication of talent it takes to reach
100,000 YouTube viewers that's you guys
we want you to know that we don't take
your achievements for granted you
deliver the audience now we're
delivering the rewards to commemorate
your milestone of 100,000 YouTube
subscribers please accept with our
congratulations this silver play button
we know you'll continue to create
amazing content and bring in more fans
so we'll keep looking for new ways to
reward you thanks for being awesome
sincerely Tom Pickett
who's the guy that does YouTube so
anyway so that was that was a note and
this is what was inside their play
button yeah I'm so excited this is so
awesome I'm gonna mount it right back
here by the incredible hulk in but those
of you were wondering about the
incredible hulk and the Iron Man picture
those were drawings that I had
commissioned we were in new york for new
york comic con I had them designed on a
friday i think it was we got we got
there thursday i think i had a
commission on friday and then picked it
up on saturday but yeah it was it was
pretty awesome like that guys forget
amazing with artwork but um but yeah so
so it says congratulations for
surpassing 100,000 subscribers how
Mike's explain i don't know if you guys
could see that try to put him where you
can see chef elephant yo a grilled piece
but um but thank you guys so much thank
you guys so much for for all the support
that you guys have given me over the
last year I mean like I mean I know
right now we're like 160 165 i'm ron
burgundy a hundred and sixty thousand
subscribers which is unbelievable um I
never imagined we'd get to this place I
know that I've bounced around I know
things have gotten kind of crazy with
the content that I've been doing and so
on and so forth and I've been trying to
get all that sorted out but you know
it's it's wild sitting down and and
realizing that that this is all just
blown up so much because of you guys and
all your support so so I want to say
thank you I want to say I appreciate it
you guys have been amazing yeah so I
don't I don't know what else to say um
we come back on Monday so yeah I'm we're
going to get into convergence we're
going to ask to answer the question what
is convergence in DC's lineup because I
think a lot of people are confused about
what convergence is about what sees what
DC is doing post convergence what's
actually convergence is a lot more
simple a lot simpler a lot more simpler
it's a lot simpler than people think it
is it's pretty straightforward so I
think you guys will enjoy that video
it'll be a pretty good explanation
on convergence why convergence is
happening what led up to convergence
different things like that so in any
event I will catch you guys later I've
actually cooking some chicken or I'm
getting ready to cook some chicken here
in a minute and yeah so that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it because I did
and I will catch you guys later peace be
sure to follow me on twitter there you
can keep up with all the updates from
comics explain and talk to me directly
away